throughout the course of the war in
Ukraine we've heard of some Americans
volunteering to fight on the front lines
but there are other ways to assist the
Ukrainian people and four friends from
New England decided they had to lend a
hand to help the youngest victims of the
conflict correspondent Charlie dagada
has their story
they are a Long Way from Home Plymouth
New Hampshire
four friends Alex Ray and Lisa Murray
Susan Matheson and Steve Rand their
mission Common Man for Ukraine mainly
helping kids and Mainly Kids who've been
orphaned by the war can I shake your
hand Timothy though today they're
visiting a school for the hearing
impaired about two hours West of Kiev
like many around the globe they watched
in horror when The Invasion began we
just looked at each other and one of us
said well we need to do something
they've raised money coordinated with
rotary clubs in Plymouth and Poland to
get help to those who needed it most
jackets
sleeping bags food
Comfort a lot of the kids had come from
areas under Russian occupation loaded
onto trains by their parents for their
own safety has it been tough on you of
course it's tough
I'm a mom
I know some put that kid on a train has
no idea how she's doing
even here far from the front lines no
child has been Untouched by the war like
eight-year-old Sasha from the besieged
city of bakmut are you happy to be here
teachers say he's hardly stopped smiling
since he arrived
thank you 14 year old Angelina fears for
her father who's gone to fight it's been
difficult for you
yes she answers it's been very hard she
doesn't want to cry
the team also runs a counseling program
in Poland we give them tools to face
their long journey ahead without a
parent in a war-torned country
they're still raising money and will
keep coming to Ukraine to remind people
the war is not over and neither is there
work here thank you so much for CBS
Saturday morning Charlie Daniel Ukraine
yeah
heartwarming yeah I feel like that last
thing the war isn't over and I know we
do stories on it each week but it wages
on and on and for them it will be years
and years and years as they're displaced
and families are changed forever she
kept us thinking about the girl who was
missing her dad right and she didn't
want to cry on camera right